Hello everybody. My name is Markipier
and welcome to The Secret of Pineview Forest.
Now take yourself back, a long
long long way back..
Hello. Hi. Can I help you?
Okay bye. Have a good day lady. Anyway
take yourselves back to a game called
"Passing Pineview Forest". This is
another game in the same series all in
relation to Pineview Drive, which is a game
that was released that was met with
mixed expectations much like the both of
these games here. But this is a free
addition to the game that supposed to
serve as a prequel to the new (pauses), the new
game that's going to be coming out.
Try to disclose the secret of Pineview Forrest
I don't know if I want to. I don't know
if that's exactly a choice I have
considering that my car blew up here. Alright that'd be
Oh I am so
Hello. Oh! press F... ouh... alright.
Ok, so at least I got a flashlight so
that's kind of good but OH MY GOD I am
SLOW.
Oh good I can run. Oh he he.
(weird markimoo sounds) I can't get over it (more markimoo sounds).
Oh hey. That's probably not a good idea to
stand near, as we wander into the forest
I can't help but be reminded, as is
whenever I play an Indie horror game taking
place in the forest,
I cannot help but be reminded of Slenderman.
Even though I know that this game
has absolutely nothing to do with that
and there's absolutely no chance that
there's any slendermen inside these
forests. All I know is that there's
something lurking in the darkness. Oh hi?
What is that? Oh it's a deer! Oh hi!
Oh woop spooked it. Ope spooked it. Okay bye. Alright. Looks like
the exact same deer from the Rake, the
multiplayer game I played with Wade
and Bob. Probably don't even... (Thunder sound) oh
lightning and thunder and it's a clear
day, night, whatever?
Oh hi again. Welcome back. You come to say
hi? Can I sneak out-? ope..
nope. Ooh it doesn't like me, doesn't like me
at all. I don't know why. I'm a nice guy.
Oh boy. (groaning in the distance) Oh, oh good, I'm gonna assume that's bears.
I'm gonna assume that's bears
mating, because it's bear mating season
out in the woods...
I don't know if that's gonna bode well
for me. It depends on how attractive I am  to
bears. (more groaning) Ok. Beginning to less and less
think that that's actually bears. Beginning to more
think that might be deathly death on the
way. Better be my shadow on the ground.
(Thunder sound) Again I, I must question the thunder
but I'm also hearing... Oh hi. Hello?!
That's odd. Why is there a cottage here? (birds cawing) Fucking
fucking fucking fucking fuck.
Hi. Ok that's fine. Just owls or birds.
(Gunshot) Hi sorry. Maybe I shouldn't go towards
the gunshot.  Okay is that good or bad? Is
that good or bad? Number one, why is there a
house right here in the middle of the
forest with no roads to go into it?
And number two, why am I walking towards a house
with a blinking light in the window?  And
number three, why am I going to (gunshot) I should
probably not go towards there. That
sounded like it came close!
Oh hi?! Oh ok. Sir are you aware of the
gunshots from that house? Uh oh. Ahh.
Okay? Yeah okay. I'm gonna, I'm, I'm, I'm gonna
assume against my better judgment here
and uh go into the building, from whence
that guy is calmly walking away from,
AFteer tah goonshots ooned wat nut.
Unless that guy's gonna come back. Don't
know why I want to go in here.
(sounds of footsteps walking away) Well that's not good. Alright bye.
Have a lovely day.
(rope swinging noises) Oh no, oh no,
oh no. Oh it's never a good sign when you
hear rope.
Oh no, oh no, oh no...
Egh egh, I don't like this. I don't like this
in any way. Heyyyy  is he back? Is he baaaack? Okay.
Yeeeet. Oh! What is that? What is that? I got
stuck on the stairs for a second there.
Is that the Blair Witch thing?
Well ok. Alright well that was a whole
lot of nothing but I got a key, so that's
guuuut. I'm so gleeeeeeed.
Okay. Yeeet yeeet yeeeeat. Ow hitting my head on this.
K. Alright then. DatBoi. Shit. Waddup.
I swear I heard footsteps out here. I'm
not mistaken about that am I? It was that dude
that was just walking away oh so calmly.
Also there seems to be one more level up,
just like a strange attic for no
apparent reason. But I've got a key.
Whatever the hell this key can go to, I have no
idea. Let's try to skedaddle our way
through here. It's actually kinda nice, just
taking (thunder) my time walking very slowly
through this game. Just trying to explore
the forest but I guess I might as well
hurry up or else I'm probably gonna die... oh no.
(owl hoots and creepy sounds) The noises are getting louder. I don't
know if that's all just in my head or
actually in the game and I'm going to
die. (creepy music picks up)
Ok. Ah ok. Ah good yes. Oh that's lovely that is.
(Thunder) Hey fucking fuck off. Is that more birds or is
that actually something?
Oh I see something.
Hello, hi it's not the guy... (crows caw) fucking stop
with the birds, birds are ok. Stop being
scared of me and I'll stop being scared
of you.
Oh no what is this and why is this out here?
And who maintains power to this light? That's my
primary concern out here. No one's going
to come out and change this goddamn
light. Who lives here? There's no path!
There's no way... oh oop ok well alrighty then.
Ok alrighty then. Well I'll just ignore the
automatically closing wooden gate
and go towards this weird hay looking structure.
Ooh there's something in the underbrush.
I see you.. the fuck is that?
Oh.. oh it's just the other thing.
Well alright then, never mind, I'm an idiot. (crows caw) Ooh
hi birds.
Yeah nothing bad about that, just birds
Just a bunch of birds, nothing to it... nothing to it.
So yeah,  I don't think anything in this forest
is actually gonna kill me, so I think I'll
be okay. Woah what the fuck? What the fuck?
Hi?! Hello King. How are you doing, out here, in
the middle of the woods? Weird statue ass thing.
Other than that, everything else has been relatively
normal. Here's a little campfire. Can't light it
on fire. (crows caw)
Whoa hello again. Alright. Again, nothing
out of the ordinary here.
(footsteps) Okay wait. Oh. I knew I heard something,
you deer bastard. Get out of here. I
thought something deadly was actually
after me.
Yep I knew I saw something. That's
another statue. Why is... this is the Queen...
why're there just these giant obelisk
Easter Egg Island statues here?
That's so weird... (more footsteps) Deer friend? I think that's
just a deer again maybe. I just feel like I'm
wandering in circles but I'm pretty sure
I'm going down a path. (footsteps) Fucking stop. Stop it!
Deer friend... deer friend?
Deer friend? That better have been you
deer friend. Birds? Anything? Alright
okay. I'll even take the King and Queen
statues. Alrighty then. Man I don't know, I just feel like
I'm wandering towards the dead end here.
Not the woods could ever be a dead end
in real-life. You kind of wander forever until
you eventually hit either an ocean, a
mountain, or civilization or death, by
bears. Oh geez it's another gate. Well where am I
now? Is there even a way through this? What is that?
Oh boy.... and where did that guy go?
Woah a horse (footsteps) fucking stop.
The fuck is that? The fuck is that? Is that
deer? That better be deer friend. Is that deer
friend? Yeah, get outta here deer friend.
Deer asshole. Spoopin me in the dark like that
when I'm by a horsey.
Alright hello horsey. How you doing? Good to
see you. You stay safe out there, you don't
know what kind of monsters are lurking.
And I don't know what kind of person has
a farm out here like this.
Well maybe this is typical but nothing
I've seen before. God dammit
deer friend. If deer friend could stop spooping for just
two seconds, I'd be very happy in my life.
Ohh hello?! What is that? What is that? What is
that? It looks like a door.
Why would there be a door out here? Why would
there be anything out here? Okay.
Alright then, maybe secret, underground bunker..
carved into the mountain face. It seems likely..
Oh it is a secret underground bunker
carved into the mountain face!
Who knew? Oh! why... I don't have another fucking key.
God dammit! I don't know where to get
another goddamn key, fuck! Alrighty then, I gotta go
back and either.... maybe the horse had a key
and I gotta kill the horse. (Yikes..)
Oh hey. Whoa. Hi? I didn't notice you before.
This may be where the crows kind of...  Jump off from..
Yeah but I definitely didn't
notice the giant dead tree in the middle
of the place. Huh? But it's gotta be - like if I
can overlook a building like that,
there's gotta be something else that I
overlooked back. I'm now back uh before
the horse area, so there has gotta be something
else... (deer call)
Whoa. Hi, deer friend.
Are you guiding me or are you warning me?
I don't know which I should be more
afraid of but one or the other.
Hello hi. Hello. How did I miss you?
How did I miss this? Oh man that's cool
and also dumb of me. But that's actually
kind of cool that this game does have
such a large map that it's easy to
overlook something as big as this, as lit
up as this. If you don't explore, how do
you expect to get anywhere in the game?
And that just makes sense. Oh there's more
Blair Witch stuff (thunder) fucking stop. Woah! Found
the depository of all the birbs. Oh boy.
So there's gotta be something obvious, most
of these doors...
whoa what the fucking fucking fuck? Did
you see that? Was that just me? There was a goddamn
fly on my screen!
The fuck was that?! What the fuck was that?
That was weird. That was really weird. What the fuck?
Oh here! Oh good I have an axe, oh I can
axe anything a question I want.
Oh. Gooood? I can't tell if that's good
but maybe I can use this to break the
lock now. God dammit, that fly! It's back!
The fuck is that?
I've never seen that. That's actually really
weird because it legitimately looks like
it's on my screen. It legitimately looks
like it's on your screen. Have you guys
been noticing that and been like
where the fuck did that fly come from?" and I
haven't said anything? That's fucking
weird.
Ok but I got an axe and I checked out
pretty much everything in that little, I
don't know, office, whatever you want to
call that. So I'm assuming that this is
what I'm gonna use to be able to bash
open the lock. (deer grunts)
Woah fucking God dammit dear friend.
I will axe you in the ass! (deer bawls) That is uh,
that is a very rude response to my
obviously illegitimate claim. You can't
take these things too seriously deer
friend. I'm not really gonna axe you
in the ass. Well actually in the face but not in the ass. (thunder) Fucking hell.
Jesus. This better be it because if it's not,
then I have no idea what I'm supposed to
be doing cause if this isn't it, then
I don't know.
Yes. Okay. Good. Maybe? Oh this seems bad.
Oh this seems the opposite of good.
Oh, oh, ohhhh no. And yes, my flashlight's on, it's
just freaking dark. Is there something at the
end of the hallway? Hi friend, you want to
be my friend? Friend, are you a friend
friend?
Well I see a dark, shadowy figure at the
end - (Creepy noises) Hi, hello?!
Oh no, my flashlight turned off and it
won't turn back on. I see you! Im coming at ya
Yeah!!!
Oh boy, oh boy, oh boy, oh boy, OH BOY, OH BOY
that's something.
Oh boy, oh boy. Okaaaay it's gone now.
Oh boy, oh boy, (music intensifies and Mark screams like a girl) oh boy, oh boy, oh God dammit get
out here fly. Fucking fly
bastard. Oh fucking fucking, don't fuck with
me.
Don't dick with me! Where am I now?
Hello? Hi, hello! You look shook. Can I help you? Oh boy.
Okay that's not working okay good to know. Okay
that works, oh oh lovely, lovely this is. What
lovely decor.
Oh boy. I got a key.
And I'm assuming (slight bang).... ooh okay, okay alright. I didn't want to
use that one anyway.
Oh gotta key... (creepy piano music)
H-hi? (music continues playing)
I can't move. (Mark screams) Fucking hell!
God dammit. Well that was a weird thing to
walk into! You can't blame me! You have been
playing the Secret of Pineview Forest. Not
bad! Not bad at all.
There are a lot of good things in this
game and it did end on a solid note, I
will say that. But it's got to be careful
because the openness of the forest was
very good, but without enough diversity
in the forest, it can rapidly become
boring. But they have a lot of good
things going on in this forest. I love the
open realm investigation; you'll find
things or maybe you won't find things.
The only problem with that is if you
require something to be found, there's
gonna be a lot of lost wandering around.
You're literally just going to be going
back and forth, which is what happened to
me. I ended up going backwards and
forward a few times, before I found that
axe. Um but other than that, there's a
lot of good element here, it had some
good spooks, it had some good atmosphere
to it, the graphics were top-notch, not
top-notch, but good enough.
Um and then like, that ending hallway was
a good bit because I didn't know if I
actually saw something until I was right
on top of it but I had a good idea.
So again, a lot of good elements here and
for a free game..
Oh! I'm on this list! Hey yaaayyy! I'm on here. So a
lot of good things but you know could be
refined a bit more but still good. So
thank you everybody so much for watching!
I wonder when this full game is gonna
come out? I'm gonna check out the
Kickstarter over there. But either way,
thank you again everybody for- oh
hi, that's creepy.
Alrighty then. Actually I'm gonna get to
the end of the credits first. Okay seems
like that might have been it. If that
scarecrow is in the game, then again they
have another game called Pineview Drive,
that is another version of the game that
came out a couple years ago, that I have
not played, but if that scarecrow
character's in it and he's sufficiently
scary, that could be a good game. But
either way, that seems to be it so thank
you everybody so much for watching and
as always, I will see you in the next
video! Bye bye! (The Best Outro Plays <3)